team in the country is a very high bar  so I'm not saying Oregon doesn't look  good they look good and they throw the  ball down the field that was something  and now they're going to get flagged for  unsportsmanlike conduct after the big  game well that kind of ruins what was a  really good play and a chance to get  into field goal range  Hudson got a got a nice gain and then  spun the ball right in the defender's  face yeah that's a Freshman Learning  point there  this is not high school anymore his head  coach is not real happy with that he's  not high school  now I I think I think this goes a bit  too far though I think there's a point  where you get his attention but you know  you know you're on national television  and let's not embarrass a young man I  think at some point you you ending you  know what I mean